[Music]
and not long enough news that's black my
dick I submitted by Jo Molly and hooker
oh [ __ ] it's my concert you actually
called the princess in Jamal yet
Jamal a hookers are princesses yeah a
man charged with attempted murder
rejected a plea deal of 20 years because
he wanted 30 years instead you know what
he wanted more time felt really guilty
because he killed his wife oh if that
will happen or he got drunk and he
killed his friends in a car accident or
he just didn't want to like be here he's
like it's easier to be in prison I'm
lazy as [ __ ] well that sucks
[Laughter]
she was exercised all right let's
continue this story is about a man named
Steven he's 40 years old yeah so he shot
a 46 year old man and left him in
critical condition so he's been charged
with attempted murder this shooting
happened last year and so when he was in
court his attorney his court-appointed
attorney which is a public defender he
was negotiating with the prosecutors and
he was able to negotiate a 20-year
sentence but that's when Steven he was
like no I don't want that man
representing me he doesn't know my case
he doesn't know what I want I don't want
20 years I want 30 years and the judge
was like I think I misunderstood and
then he was like no you heard me right I
was offered 30 years he came to me with
20 and I told him I wasn't gonna accept
the 20 I wanted the 30 if he can't get
me the 30 years I don't want to see him
anymore I don't think he knows how this
works
he thinks is money that's what he thinks
right now hold on said you tell me right
now you gonna give me what 25 Oh God
nobody's thinking he wants 30 years in
jail and so but we don't know why we
don't know why that's so weird
yeah I don't know why you but he's
arguing as if it's less I've never heard
he's refusing his public defender and he
wants to be able to represent himself
and the judge is still like talking to
the defender
during court he's like why are you
denying me my constitutional right to
represent myself
he can't proceed with my case and
doesn't know anything and I won't tell
him anything
I have a right to counsel to my
satisfaction you're a judge and you know
this is what he was telling the judge
during court I could just like picture
him in court and it's like first
statement people of the court I'll be
this year but yeah just like what the
[ __ ] I don't get this guy what's what's
going on is he like you don't tell me
how many years I do I tell you I think
they didn't reverse I called you on his
ass that's what it sounds like right now
huh the judge so so Steven kept making
all these outbursts which changes name
cuz my name is Steven - I feel like what
do you want - Steven school he was just
having all these outbursts and that's
when the judge warned him and then
hasn't even unleashed a profanity filled
rant and then that's when the judge was
like you know I'm holding you in
contempt and he was held in contempt
for a total of I believe it was six
counts six counts of contempt thank you
your honor
[Laughter]
so these six counts of contempt amounts
to three years 3-year sentence but you
can't do war [ __ ] that's what
the judge was saying like quote I'm
quite concerned about your mental
ability to move forward and then Stephen
said I'm concerned about your mental
ability to judge this case get me out of
this courtroom and take me downstairs
I've a feeling like you super problem
self - he's not called like his wife is
I guess what baby there would be 20 but
I got 33 [ __ ] is going on you know it's
funny what if they dangled it in front
of them like a child like do you want 20
years or 30 years and he's like I'll
take the 30 thirty sounds good yeah
I'm gonna cheat me out of ten years
forgetting the 30 and also he filed for
pending lawsuits over the last year
alleging harsh conditions in the prison
or in the jail and so the Sheriff's
Office dismissed the lawsuits as
baseless because they were like there's
no reason what's the harsh conditions me
a nap ba yeah I don't know the harsh
condition but he looks like Muhammad Ali
she looks like a fatter Muhammad Ali's
yeah poor Stephen huh yeah and so now we
all team out of the court and said the
judge said that you do hmm oh yeah
they're gonna evaluate come on you
telling me that I'm gonna get 20 years
I need 39 I'm thinking like he's 40 he
wants to get out of jail he's 70 that's
it I don't think he's thinking that yeah
I think he's thinking no I want the
first deal that I got why are you trying
to lessen my deal he's not even
listening to the number or what's behind
that what the number represents
do you understand the think she does
jail time and I don't know but he's
we're gonna be getting an evaluation
wait why was he in there why did why did
he attempted murder he shot a 46 year
old and left him in critical condition I
don't know man this guy sounds pretty
funny though I bet you he's a comedian
I'm just want a bit no it'd be very
frustrating cuz you're trying to get to
a point right you're trying to get to
something in a conversation but this
guy's arguing some irrelevant illogical
[ __ ] you're gonna be like [ __ ] I [ __ ]
hate you I like everybody on Twitter to
me and you're always trying to blow up
on people this is true I don't know I
can't do prison no prison that made for
me I'm almost 100% sure I already know
who in this room is going to survive
prison be best well that guy do these
demons know I scared of prison
I wouldn't last a day I wouldn't last a
day but I would be prime pickings hey
little we got a new fish new fish
he's Thai he looked tight oh my god yeah
you're gonna survive real good oh they
would just be all over me I heard I mean
you have to kick ass right that's what I
heard well then what do you do what do
you do then somebody of like Bart comes
up to you at that point so this is your
first day in prison right
you got you a little lunch tray with
your [ __ ] food you sit down and it's
Bart shirtless his [ __ ] dick halfway
hanging out softer comes out he gonna
come to the Eagles what's up fish sauce
that's what that's what he calls you by
the way your fish sauce now what's up
fish sauce suck this bigger what what do
you do yeah Christian are we there for
life you're there for over there for
three days for a DUI 20 years
oh yeah that's pretty much life this is
a twin make it 20 minutes man but you
have to tell and yeah I wouldn't make it
bro
I would not make it I would have to do
something I'll jump off the rail I would
try to kill my I would not want to do 20
20 years man I would definitely try to
kill myself I jump up like this I'm
[ __ ] let's have an America me when I
would do that to myself without getting
shanked so bar would just come up here
he's like what's up fish sauce you like
excuse me don't you to my face I would
find the lead that's my fear I would not
want to get butt-fucked so this is what
you got to do you find the leader of
every race has a leader right we're
gonna be we're gonna be in the Asian
side you're gonna have to suck up Bart
do so you find the leader you go up to
them and you give them an offering with
your mouth also what if he's like let's
get off me I'm not even gay dude
you just get up there sir oh yeah I'm
not gay that'd be so funny if you just
did it without even asking yeah I'm some
fresh meat all right what the [ __ ] go to
the white people did that be the worst
that he's saying he's not gay
using me yeah being their little geisha
girl whatever got Lucy Liu here hey
Trevor you want you got [ __ ] we got a
[ __ ] good boy you know every time I
think about I would take a razor blade
it's done I would not want to live I
would not want to get it exit only baby
comes out nothing goes in here poo
that's it don't get the smell of it I
would make make it so disgusting for
them to [ __ ] me like they would be
[ __ ] me and I'd be [ __ ] like like
diarrhea although what if they're you I
wouldn't worry I would try cuz it might
be used to that what the [ __ ] coming on
now there's no enemas in there like [ __ ]
Oh why'd you have to say it like a
thousand percent sure though if I'm
gonna stay in prison for the rest of my
life and somebody help me try to suck
their dick I probably go down and I rip
that [ __ ] off my [ __ ] teeth there's
no point I'm gonna be there at like oh
then you get the you get the reputation
of the dick blind a fighter that's all I
got to do you see you gave up too soon
well you want to fight fire with fire
eventually they're gonna knock out your
teeth so you could suck dick very softly
I have a better method they could take
this but they can't take this I'm gonna
learn to love it
[Laughter]
[Music]